we wouldn't even be discussing a
referendum if it hadn't been for you
kick growing in 2012 in the polls and
Cameron reversing you turning once again
don't forget Dave in 2008 I give you a
cast-iron guarantee by 2011-12 no
referendum not necessary not in our
interest and in 2013 Dave wants to give
you a referendum he's only talking about
it because of you given the way to get a
referendum is to get enough you give MPs
into Westminster next year freedom of
movement was on the agenda at the Tory
Party conference in front of the
faithful as an attempt to calm them in
the nation that he might do something
about it and simultaneously to him
saying that in the hall in Birmingham in
Brussels everybody else was saying this
is not up for grabs and Cameron does
this again and again he raises
expectations he thinks by doing this
somehow you Kip and Euroskeptic thought
will melt away it won't exactly I think
you guys in Westminster you know well
yeah but you spent too long in
Westminster clearly I think you guys in
Westminster just don't understand what's
happening in the country the north of
England is as you're a skeptic if not
more Euroskeptic than the south of
England east of england the west of
england and if you look at the european
election results you know back in May
22nd this year with a whole of South
Yorkshire when you care large parts of a
Northwest you get top the pole yes there
is um well how could you not it's the
same thing you cannot have an
immigration policy you cannot predict
the numbers that come into Britain you
cannot predict what primary school
provision you need you cannot predict
what NHS provision you need if your
members of a union that gives an open
door to nearly half a billion people
I'm rebelling against the established
your total creature of this stuff please
x dot stock broker noise college no I
wasn't stop Shia Tory background oh and
i worked in the metals business nothing
wrong with that is there I'm not do
something that's anyone right anyone I
tell you what you've been hit before you
could say I tell you what's not a con
unlike Miliband Clegg Cameron and
virtually all of the others at 18 years
old i got up at five o'clock in the
morning I went to work I work for 20
years you know paper taxes in the mram
own cabinet employ people I've worked in
the real world I know what it's like Lee
goes through tough times I know what
it's like to deal with bureaucracy and
none of them frankly have ever had a job
no I'm a metal trailer try again but
trader you're a man of the city and it's
the city that calls the woes of your
training I'm trying to play man in
equation duel to buy some lead was there
any letter I got copper aluminium I
don't mind I'm sorry and there is there
is one way which I would agree with you
and that is that the eurozone crisis has
led to many more people coming to this
country and I suspect between now in the
general election the numbers coming to
Britain will go up even further so
desperate is the financial crisis in
Italy and Spain and Portugal and Greece
we have yes of course we had huge
problems from 2008 as many Western world
countries did because big what we've
mismanaged it completely we torn up the
rulebook a robot that have been there
since the Wall Street Crash we tore it
up Gordon Brown gave away control of the
banks that have been run by the bank of
england sits 1694 and gave it to a bunch
of tick box box bureaucrat failures down
in Canary Wharf that is why the banking
crisis was as bad as it was and you'll
notice countries like Canada on
Australia did not have a banking crisis
as we did because they kept proper rules
you're making a big flavor you might win
this with you really well but if you
lose you'll see that your appeal it's
not your shiet Oriole your free market
he'll does not run so in place a greater
manchester home with the trade I just
think you're not seeing the ball you
know we are we are growing hugely in the
north of England we come second and in
the last five northern by-elections this
is our best by-election yet to date in
the north you know I'm absolutely
confident this will be our best ever
score in a by-election in the north of
England and let's see where that puts us
in relation to the Labour Party all I'm
saying is this I except it's a mountain
to climb labour a well-entrenched
they're well organized the well-funded
and all of those things but we've got
some momentum with us wake up go to bed
Nigel Farage quite funny by his
standards I'm I say yeah I'll give him
that it wasn't bad but it's nonsense
it's a desperate attempt by Cameron to
try to hold on to that Tory boat that's
left with him a third of its gone since
the election between now and the
election it's likely the dead Miliband
will match that referendum pledge then
he won't even be able to say that are
you a free market do I believe in free
markets or do I believe in communism I
prefer free markets do I think do I
think free markets need to have limits
do I think do I'm even the most ardent
free marketeer believes that a
government should have a central bank
should have a fiscal policy and a
monetary policy and I would extend that
by saying we must be mad not to have our
own labor market policy and to have open
the doors to over the doors to
unconditional numbers of people may be
good for big employers I accept that but
the social consequence of that has not
been worth the price we have no problem
with the NHS having more private
contractors
some well I think what's interesting I'd
like that I think what's interesting is
this it was the Labour government that
introduced PF ideals bringing him big
outside private money it was the Labour
government in areas like this that
outsourced many of the services within
hospitals to foreign companies in some
cases owned by goldman sachs so it so it
so it really is no I tell you what I
want I want us to run our own government
departments correctly and I think what
has happened since 1987 not just in the
NHS but across a wide range of public
services is we've outsourced various
things that government itself used to do
and we've done it to the betterment of
very many rich individuals they've done
very well out of it but I don't think
we've got better better public services
out of it I want government to run the
bits that government runs and running
well what what my view is that it is not
a patriotic thing to give away your
democracy your birthright your freedom
your ability to control your own destiny
to a foreign set of institutions over
which you only have a very small
percentage say I think that is actually
giving away the country selling the
country down the river and that is what
the career political class in Britain
have done they've done it over decades
they've done it by stealth they've done
it without ever telling us the truth and
I think what's happening is that the
Penny's dropped and the British people
increasingly saying look we want to be
friendly with Europe course we want to
trade with Europe do all the things that
neighbors can do but we want back our
country in our democracy because teeth
it is is very very badly drafted and
it's badly drafted because there are so
many countries that'll be part of that
that are not part of the common law
system they have a committee different
legal system that the Americans have
written it in such a way that says they
don't trust the legal system of over
half of Europe and it's put us into
something that has a dispute mechanism
that actually would override our
democracy and our court and it's not
acceptable I'm opposed to it on these
terms I'm not opposed to trade I'm
opposed having the right trade deals but
I think Britain the sixth biggest
economy in the world should negotiate
its own trade deals not have it done by
a bureaucrat in Brussels to try and
balance the interests
of 28 different countries yeah labor
line I think it's getting a hearing here
is the new basically it's all the new
vittoria sumotori do offer scales what
the labor message is that we want to
privatize the NHS that's a lie and the
message that somehow you keep his uber
tori is alike we have got policies that
are more in tune with helping working
people in Britain the net Miliband has
his government his government which he
was a part of minister opened the doors
in 2004 to completely unconditional
numbers of labor coming for eastern and
southern Europe it is that that as
compressed wages it is that that has
displaced British people in the
workplace and EDD Miliband knows it but
he dens admitted are you basically is
this a long-term strategy you don't see
what the SF based on you're hoping to
move into second place and if even if
this proves you here this time well
we're fighting a battle on many fronts
at the moment I mean this by-election
which cleared is very important to us
klaxon happens on the same day we've
then in the next month going to have all
end of October we've got the police and
crime Commissioner in Yorkshire and then
we'll have the Rochester by-election in
November so we are up to here fighting
elections at the moment ask me after
those four results and that million
pounds though it came from in the guy
who's diamond mines that is gonna go
down to you well on the streets of
middle I think he has insurance
companies and I bet many people have
fire insurance on their house is that is
that bad then what are you saying that's
not a it's not your tip you're saying
your every day laborer blow working and
you take it million pounds we're not
funded by the state we're not funded by
John trade unions and we haven't sold
peerages all right the way that british
politics is funded is through those
means so far this year the tour is
appraised 14 million in big donations
the Labour Party have raised 10 million
in big donations we've raised two
million now three million in big
donations it is very difficult to fight
against the established political
parties in this country without the fuel
and the ammunition to do so so for us
yesterday that donation makes a very big
difference